a girl friend of mine who is a mostly
lesbian bisexual and she usually sleeps
with women that's the thing but she also
sometimes sleeps with men and she said
it's really interesting thinking about
the way that coming off the pill change
but then she said one other thing that I
noticed when I came off the pill was
that for one week out of every month I
was straight again have you ever come
across that before I can't even begin to
tell you how many women I've heard that
from I've heard of a lot of bisexual
women who get nudged one way or the
other depending on where they are in the
cycle I've heard from women who thought
that they were bisexual and then went on
or off the birth control pill and then
had that change where they were either
completely straight or thought that they
were completely lesbian did you manage
to find a significant swing in one way
or the other the thing I've heard most
frequently is that they become a little
more straight when they're off the pill
researchers have long suspected a roll
of steroid hormones in terms of actual
preference and the story that you just
told and the stories I've heard from
women are very much consistent with sort
of hormonal nudges